one
alrighty thank you for hanging out with
me appreciate that
sorry I'm a little late to get started I
was missing an adapter
left I think I left it here last talk
and I just need to find it
all my adapters have my name and phone
number on them
so if you want my phone number
steal one of my adapters
all right
I have been blogging since April of 2002
so that's 20 years I've been taking a
break for the last couple months because
I'm tired but I've been blogging every
Tuesday and Thursday for the last 20
years
I also have a podcast called Hansel
minutes
that is named Hansel minutes because I'm
a very bad estimator
people would ask me how long something
would take and I'd say about 30 minutes
and they would say are those Hansel
minutes or a real minutes
the podcast has been going on for
837 episodes
that's every Thursday
for the last 16 years
yeah a long time
that's what old looks like
and um
it's worth pointing out that for the
most part this is a room full of old
white guys some young white guys
you know what a collective noun is
like a gaggle of geese
or a pride of lions this is a called a
collective noun when you have more of
something it's a pride of lions I don't
know if they have that in different
languages it's a very English thing just
French or German or I think what what
language do you speak
Dutch they got that in Dutch just random
words that they pick up like a
a wire of computer programmers just make
up a word like that
yeah
well if you have more than two white
guys it's a podcast of white guys
and and that's not a good thing so uh
you can take a look at the show here and
notice that I I found that there's a lot
of cool people in Tech doing a lot of
really cool work and I'm not having any
trouble finding cool people from all
over the world of all genders and
flavors and one of the great things
about having a show that goes back 800
episodes is I'm just flicking
still scrolling I could probably give
the whole talk and I'm still only in the
600s so if you are interested in hearing
from people who don't look like you and
maybe inviting them to speak at your
conference
here are 837 people who have been
pre-vetted to give great talks
because they have given a great talk to
me and they go on and I'm still only in
the 400s and I'm still going not running
out of people isn't that great
so I have hanselman.com
I have the Hanselman blog and I have the
podcast
this
is Hanselman International
and I make dozens of dollars on on
Hanselman International I think I made
eight dollars on Tick Tock last month
eight dollars and 37 cents
I made 150
on YouTube it's not Nick chapas money
but it's pretty good uh and uh and then
the blog has some advertising and stuff
like that right so I have a staff of me
and uh it's a it's an international
wide-ranging company
I have offices in every country
Starbucks
and uh
before Microsoft I was what's called an
MVP Microsoft virtual professional
whatever most valuable professional it's
basically they just go you're cool
here's free stuff
and one of the free things that they
give you is hosting now now they give
you some Azure money I think you get a
hundred bucks of azure money or an msdn
okay but back in the day in the late 90s
they would have third parties give you
stuff so you'd get like teleric controls
or infraristics controls and there was a
company called Orcs web that gave me a
virtual machine
hey free virtual machine that's cool
I'll put my blog there
so they say hey you're an MVP here's a
free virtual machine it's a 50 value
cool
so free stuff I love free stuff so I get
a Windows Server 2003 VM
our remote desktop directly into
production the way God intended us
it's called it's called hanselmanning
into production
right and I just FTP my files into IIs
and I put hanselman.com up and I hey I'm
blogging it's free right 20 years ago
and it works great and I'm using this
great blogging engine it's called dos
blog
which is German for the blog
it's true you have to say it like a Dos
Vlog yeah for my Germans
I can say that I can make fun of Germans
because Hanselman is a German name with
the two ends we lost one end going
across the ocean where's the other end
but every time I go back to Germany they
see this German face and the German
glass just think oh how handsome
sorry man I don't speak German
um
there's actually a handsome and bakery
in Holland two ends I need to go and get
some free food because that must be a
cousin
so all of this is on a Windows Server
2003 and if you've ever used IIs
internet information server it's you you
go into the IIs what's it called MMC
what does MMC stand for something
something console Microsoft Management
console there it is thank you appreciate
that Dylan so you go to the Management
console and you have this tree so
basically one server equals one uh Port
Port 80 and then you have applications
and an application runs in its own
memory space you could run everything in
its own memory space but I basically had
three apps I had the podcast I had the
home page of the website which was a
separate app from slash blog
and this is going to be important later
because URLs matter
so right here
we have hanselman.com and then if we hit
slash blog
that's a separate app
okay and this was on dos blog Das blog
running on.net to
and then running later on.net three and
I was just kind of living my life doing
my thing and everything was great and
then I started getting the yellow screen
of death
familiar with the yellow screen of death
you hit a.net website and you you're not
very you're not very good at your job
and you've poorly configured it and it
usually says you should not be seeing
this in production and then it gives you
the source code of the website
so that was bad uh and I hadn't set up
any kind of devops or you know pager
Duty or pingdom these are those web web
applications that will text you when
your website goes down instead people
tweet me
so Twitter is like yeah answer one your
blog is down oh thank you that's
embarrassing
um
and I got a particular yellow screen of
death that said you're out of disk space
I didn't know that I have a virtual
machine right I have unlimited disk
space
so I call the company called orcsweb and
I said can you give me more space uh on
the virtual disk and they said who are
you
and I said well I'm Scott Hanselman you
gave me a web you gave me a thing later
and I said well Works web has been sold
we're not orcsweb anymore the company
doesn't exist
I said but my website's still up
so how is that a thing
well we sold it to these quebecua in in
the french-speaking part of Canada and
it's called sherweb that's very
different name uh so orcsweb has become
sure web and now they have a French
accent and
so I call them I go oh
it's me uh I have a website and uh they
said
who are you I said I'm Scott Hanselman I
have a website and I said well
we have no record of you existing
I said my website's still up though I
can ping it I know it's a thing like I
can ping hanselman.com and it goes to
our website and he says I'll call you
back uh and he calls me back and it
turns out
I never had a virtual machine
it was a physical computer
uh and it was under Jeff's desk
but now Jeff is gone
so now it's a physical computer
under alaine's desk
they had this idea that they were going
to give all the MVPs virtual machines
but they didn't have enough so they just
took a mini tower
and they put my they put a computer on
it and they put it under this guy's desk
and then they sold it and they you know
I had a note like don't turn this off or
something and they they ended up taking
it to the uh the hosting service and
then putting it on a shelf and plugging
it in and they forgot about it
and I said well that's problematic as
the kids say and uh could you maybe
expand the hard drive and they said well
I don't think you understand
this is this is a spinning rust hard
drive like you can hear it
right and if you're old enough to
remember when you could hear your your
hard drive that's not a good thing if
you can hear your hard drive right and
this is really important because a lot
of young people don't understand like
what the cloud is for or how it works or
why it exists right the cloud is just a
fancy way of saying other people's
computers
that's all it is why you look young I'm
going to say you're a crisp 29. uh
you're probably 22 but that's fine these
shoes are 22.
um
have you ever seen the cloud have you
ever been there you ever been to a
Hoster
okay well it's like what's like a
refrigerators right it's just like
rows and rows and rows
have you seen the end of Indiana Jones
yeah that's the cloud when they push
everything in that's where my computer
is
it's in one of those boxes at the end of
Indiana Jones
yeah so uh I I I needed them to find it
and one of the great things about the
cloud and the difference between the
cloud and hosting is that with the CL
with hosting you can visit your computer
it's like if you send one of your
relatives or grandma or Grandpa to the
home you can go and check on them but
the cloud is like they're in the home
and you don't know where they are
there's a piece of Grandma here and a
piece over there and they're spread out
across them it's really a messy analogy
the point is you could go up to the
computer and you could have your laptop
and then push refresh
and you could hear the hard drive go
click click
and you go refresh and there's a direct
relationship between the page loaded and
the computer did some stuff okay but
with the cloud the hard drive is here
and the memory is over there and the
processors over there and it's all
connected with software-based networking
so I have a situation where I'm in the
U.S in Portland Oregon and my computer
is under someone's desk in Quebec and I
don't speak French and I have a 30 gig
hard drive
I don't know about you but I've
accidentally swallowed 30 gigs you know
you put an SD card in your mouth and you
turn around and oh my God
64 gigs is gone like that right
so 30 gigs is not a lot of space so I'm
remote desktopping into this thing into
production deleting log files on the
regular I've even written a script and I
I'm literally like 100 megabytes
you know and then you hit refresh and
explore and you see it's like 60
megabytes 30 megabytes and then yellow
screen adapt so it's getting really bad
now I had eventually had a plan that I
was going to go and upgrade this thing
but now I don't have a plan I have a
deadline which is different
okay so let's talk about
let's talk about why this is a problem
and how this became incredibly scary and
stressful
because keeping in mind that I have
dozens of dollars to deal with here
where budget is minimal
don't ever trust an Azure sales person
who gets their their Azure time for free
only pay only trust them if they pay
with their own money
so I pay with my own money okay so I've
got these three websites
hanselman.com is brochureware brochure
where
it's like a super basic website
and then this is a Blog it's kind of
sophisticated it was on.net2o that's
Windows only
that's a problem this is on Razer Pages
slash MVC it's a little bit newer I
think it was.net4 and this is all
running on Windows server
2003.
some of you were not born then
there's a lot wrong here there's a lot
wrong here sorry
um
Windows Server 2003 was great in 2003
and even 2004. uh but there's things
that you want it to do that it can't do
like TLS which is secure sockets turns
out that Windows Server 2003 like
supported like TLS 1.2 but doesn't do
1.3 so now I'm patching dlls on an
actual physical server with that you can
hear that's clicking there's another
thing that's a problem
this is a 19 year old computer do you
know what mtbf is
who wants to tell me what that is
mean time before failure mean being
average time before failure so uh does
anyone have a really old cat
s are not supposed to be 23. God bless
them they're just not uh neither are
hard drives and certainly not ones that
spin
the meantime before failure of a hard
drive at the time that I purchased this
Hardware was about five years now it's
about seven which is a lie because it's
really five
so I have a I have a 19 year old a hard
drive here uh not only can this be a
problem if your cat is that old but if
you ever had a car that you're afraid to
stop
because it may not start again
I know in my soul if this hard drive
stops spinning it is never gonna start
again
so I got to get this stuff off it too
sweet as the quebecua say
so that's a problem
doesn't do TLS it's spinning I'm on
borrowed time this is a huge problem so
I first I back it all up
back it all up back it all up so that's
handled at least I've got copies of
everything but
when I built the thing
I'm one I'm a one one person shop
right remember when Microsoft was
telling you to right click and publish
in Visual Studio
at least we right click and publish to
GitHub which then builds in GitHub and
then does devops right at least it's
devopsy but um right click I was just
right into production right if your
deployment strategy is opening two
Explorer windows and copying dlls from
one folder to another that's probably
not a deployment strategy that was my
deployment strategy for a number of
years that's like when your source code
strategy is a ZIP file
it says v1.zip v2.zip these were these
were different times friends
so I don't trust the code I can't build
it reliably it only runs on Windows it
only runs on this one machine so what
would be the naive way to move this to
the cloud it would be totally valid and
businesses do it every day there's even
a fancy word for it
lift and shift
lift and shift is a lie it's a bad bad
idea right it's what we tell people
you're going to do digital
transformation oh my goodness what am I
going to do you're going to lift and
shift into the cloud I'm going to take
an image of the disk that is about to
die that's too small and I'm going to
put an image of it
in the cloud
and then I'll make it a little bit
bigger right it's just I'm going to
upload your brain into the Matrix and
you're still on Windows Server 2003 you
just don't really exist in the physical
world anymore
that is not a good idea because I'm
really putting a Band-Aid or a bandage
on cancer
right this thing is going to die
and I'm just keeping it alive in
you know the Neo Matrix kind of a world
so that was that was a thing I could do
that though I would do what's called
disk to vhd it's a tool you can get from
CIS internals it takes an image of the
disk puts it into an image file and then
you run the image file in the cloud that
would be a a patch that was my my oh
[ __ ] button you know oh [ __ ] put the
button that would be what I would do
but I feel like I can do better than
that uh so I have a problem with trust I
have a problem with security I have a
problem with source so we got Source we
got trust we got security when I say
trust I mean I don't trust that I can
build the thing again
so the first thing I wanted to do was
figure out if I could run this thing on
platform as a service because I don't
want to do is is infrastructure as a
service infrastructure as a service is
fine but it's like
free like a puppy you know like here's a
puppy oh a puppy I love puppies you
gotta feed it you gotta water it you
gotta keep it I don't have dogs I don't
know what you have to do with dogs but
there's watering in there somewhere
right this is all the stuff like oh I'm
so happy I have a free puppy if you give
someone gives you a free Windows machine
in the cloud you have to remote in you
got to run Windows update you got to
manage it you got to talk to it with a
Powershell even if they give you a free
Linux machine in the cloud you got to go
an app to get upgrade and apt kit update
you gotta you gotta maintain it or you
got to pay somebody to maintain it
because you're deciding that your
agreement your relationship with the
computer is going to be at the kernel
level
think about that for a second I'm
writing an app that does blogging and
I'm going to to agree that that what the
kernel provides is the is the level that
I am interested in I want memory I want
hard drive and I want kernel calls
and that means that in 20 years it's
going to be an old version of something
that I never really thought about
platform as a service says I don't care
about the operating system that much I
don't care about the kernel I care about
the platform that I wrote it on node.net
python PHP whatever the version of that
is what matters if you go into Azure and
you make a new app service
you just say I want node or I want.net
you don't even need to think about the
underlying operating system I don't know
what version of Windows those things run
on top of or what version of Linux I
don't care
so the analogy would be I can buy a car
and I think about the engine and I care
about the brand of the car
or I just rent a car I don't care four
doors
all right you don't go and rent a car
and say I want a Honda
no you say four doors or two doors these
are the basic things that you care I
don't really care and then you you don't
treat the car very well when you rent a
car do you
right like my hotel room right I've
completely thrashed my hotel room here
at the conference because I'm a rock
star right and I expect that when I
return to the hotel room it'll be put
back together because it's platform as a
service right so my job is to just flip
the beds over and just eat all the
snacks and then come back and it's been
put back together right I'm not really
doing that I make the bed but the point
is that's the kind of relationship now
if I owned the house I would treat it
better
so you treat physical machines
differently you treat virtual machines
driven you you deal with them you weed
the garden and you clean them up so
platform as a service would be a really
nice place to start but Windows costs a
little bit more so I want to move
everything over to Linux
so a couple things that I needed to do
was figure out what's the easiest thing
and what's the hardest thing so I sorted
these and I figured that a brochure wear
site would be the easiest the podcast
would be the second easiest and the blog
would be the hardest so the brochure
wear site was using Razer Pages which is
uh was
mvc3.net four was not a big deal to move
it over into
um
uh move it over into uh into.net core
looking at my my Explorer down there I
don't know why my icons are hard to see
foreign
I think I'm at a weird resolution sorry
about that give me one second
check my resolution
and then Blow Away Windows Explorer
because it's confused
and still confused you're going to just
be down there in the corner aren't you
all right we won't be launching files
that way
we'll go into terminal
we'll go over here
so this is my I'm using Windows terminal
if you didn't see before this is called
oh my Posh which gives me that nice
prompt you can see the folder you can
see my blood sugar in real time right
there 100 is good if it's lower than
that let me know I've got my branch that
is real by the way I'm not joking I'm
Type 1 diabetic I have implants and
Insulin pumps and they talk to the cloud
which also needs to run platform as a
service or I'll die
and then it's true
and then each time I hit enter it makes
a web service call to get my blood sugar
and then that's really important because
notice that it's on the left it's more
important than my git branch which is
secondarily as important as my blood
sugar and then my current version of.net
so this particular app I can go and run
code Dot and we'll bring up visual
studio code real quick and we trust
everything and this is a nice simple
application it was not complicated all
the defaults are here nothing fancy the
only thing I added was a robots.txt file
for SEO purposes to tell my system
through Google that I wanted certain
things
um
spidered and I've got like the books
I've written in my about page and an
index my list of podcasts these are
pretty straightforward Pages moving this
over to.net was not hard.net core so if
we go to hanselman.com we can see that
that loads very fast and it's got the
about page and the list of podcasts it's
got my newsletter and it works pretty
well
what I added at the bottom
was a little real-time powered by thing
here that's not actually
um
static text I'm actually looking at that
and pulling it out of the dll
and when I got that running on.net
and I can run it locally I then wanted
to switch over to Ubuntu in another tab
here I'm going to go ahead and click
Ubuntu and I'm going to open a split
pane
and now I've got Linux on the right and
windows on the left over here
and then we're going to go into
Hanselman
core which is in a different file system
and I'm going to say.net build
so now I can run it in both Linux and
windows the reason that I did that is I
wanted choice because I was seeing
places that would let me host Linux for
30 less than Windows so being able to
have these things run in two places was
important it was also a practice run to
see if I could get the blog and the
podcast running on Linux as well so I'm
going from.net 2 to 4 then from four to
six and trying to figure out what would
work and what wouldn't
because it's cross-platform I want to
make sure that I'm not using any Windows
specific apis there's no registry on
Linux so I can't call the registry the
only bugs that I found were pathing bugs
where I was assuming a backslash instead
of a forward slash but there's
system.io.path.directory separator and
things like that so just constants for
backslashes versus forward slashes so
there were places I was writing to the
file system other than that it literally
just works it's super actually creepy
how well it works and it's valuable even
if you deploy to Windows today to just
have it running in both places so that
you know that you can if you ever want
to move what was cool about that then is
I could then because it's running on
Linux very quickly and easily get it
running on docker so I did that next
experiment with my
uh podcast site
which is
how you like my cool stuff like that
isn't that neat
I have a whole article on my blog about
your ultimate command line setup I can
do coloring I can do auto complete as a
history drop down makes life a lot
easier I don't use CD I use a thing
called Z which is faster and cooler
so I'm going to bring up code so this is
my podcast and then I made a Docker file
one of the great things about having
your own website is you're running
something in production and you're
learning about production on a thing
that doesn't really matter
this is really really powerful I
recommend this to anyone no matter where
they are in their career whether they're
earlier and later this is the equivalent
of having an old car that you don't need
to commute in your garage that you can
always be tinkering with right my
podcast site doesn't really matter like
I said I'm not making any money on it so
if it's down for a couple of hours fine
but I feel like there's a lot of people
who are in a business where they know
about their slice of an app or their
slice of a website but they're not full
stack Developers
but it's hard to be a full stack
developer and know the complete
amazon.com no one could know it it's too
big
but I know every single thing on this
website and all three of these websites
and what's cool about that is Docker
comes out huh I wonder if I can use
Docker on my website
hey redis is a thing maybe I'll cash
some stuff in redis Azure platform as a
service I'll put some stuff in platform
as a service it doesn't work I'll roll
it back
GitHub actions Azure devops like when a
new thing comes out I try it out and if
it works I keep it and what's cool about
this is that of course I've been running
uh sites for longer than this but no one
carries the pager but me when the site
goes down I hear about it and I'm
responsible for its uptime when SSL
certificates expire it's on me to come
up with a plan for that
and then I can decide is right click
publish in Visual Studio a good idea or
do I need devops
do I how do I do Source control do I
pull do I do pull requests to myself
running your own website even if it's
just a static web app is how you learn a
ton about systems I see a lot of people
who are early in career putting together
a very simplistic portfolios and I just
really love to see a complete
simple website just a Blog that you run
yourself because what I want to hear is
that you have stories about it going
down and you brought it back to life so
I can tell you stories about breaking
things about getting attacked by
spammers and all that kind of there's
all kinds of cool stuff that you only
learn when you do these things in
production so here I've got dot net six
I learned all about Docker I'm going to
show you this really quick this is cool
this is called a multi-stage build file
notice on line one it says as build so
you're creating a container you're
compiling the code in that container
it's named build
and then when you're done
you run.net build so now the result of
the the output of that container
lives in that that container called
build
then based on build you create a new one
called publish and you make a working
directory and you publish the.net
application into an output folder
so now I have a container with all of my
applications in it and what's
interesting about it is it's got the SDK
the compiler a bunch of stuff I don't
want to ship
I don't need that surface area the
security surface area of that so then
take a look at line 33 we then switch to
a different container that's just the
runtime for.net
and then we copy on line 35 that out
folder
so the building happens with the
compiler and it's a big heavy container
it's like 300 Megs it's got olive.net
and everything I need to build
then the result moves over to a tiny
runtime container that's like 100 Megs
and then I go and do that I had been
publishing I didn't know about this I've
been publishing the whole thing all
of.net the.net SDK and the compiler and
everything so I learned about
multi-stage build files and then you see
the entry point there on line 36 where I
can run my application in a in a
container
so already I'm making progress moving
stuff over and then I went and wrote a
little Docker build PS file little PS1 a
little Powershell script
and uh am I running Docker that might
actually work I think I need to run
Docker first I don't think I'm running
Docker right now so let me fire up
Docker I don't know what's going on with
my uh
my toolbar there something so you see
how I'm seeing um the lower part of the
screen there
being cut off
so I'm just going to pretend that I know
what's happening down here
that looks like the top of someone's
head there I don't know what's going on
let's try again see if my doctor is
going to build
working in the dark here
it's good though because if things
always work then it doesn't there you go
it's no fun there you go so now we're
building that entire application in
docker
I was surprised how 17 18 year old code
in.net easily moved over into dot net
core six it was pretty cool just as an
example if you take a look at my tweets
in the last couple of days I wrote an
application a while ago called Baby
smash baby smash.com it is a game for
little kids for babies they can smash
the keyboard and it puts letters and
numbers and sings and dances and talks
to them and stuff like that my baby is
16 and driving
somebody ported it over to avalonia
which is an open source framework based
on WPF and now it runs on a Mac
so the baby is 16 baby smash lives on
and I actually have a donate button on
the baby smash website I get about eight
dollars a month on baby smash
so if you know for 16 years
that's uh it's big money
true story uh it's been like 60 bucks
right so that was an example where an
application was created in you know 16
years ago and has now moved over to the
cloud as well so here now this is
actually running that application's
running and running tests so I'm
actually running X unit text tests
inside of of Docker itself now I was
using selenium selenium is a unit
testing application that lets you
actually click on buttons but I'm
finding it to be a little bit unreliable
so I'm going to translate it over to a
thing called playwright and playwright
runs in a container headless and it
works really well so I'm going to learn
about playwright on a real website as
opposed to just doing a tutorial so
again a little bit of an advertisement
there to go and learn how to do these
things yourself so there you go so now
I've gone and I've tagged podcast latest
so I can say Docker images
and there we go created 23 seconds ago
I've got my podcast site running in in
docker
so then I can go over to the
website let's go to my personal profile
I'm going to go to azure
go to the Azure portal here real quick
nope
nope
logging in logging in
this should make like wait or hold music
or something when you do this stuff
dude no it's still me go away
take a look at my application running up
in azure
and we have app service plan
I'm using my msdn
here we go an app service plan
is actually a virtual machine of sorts
you see I've got four applications
running on a single app service a lot of
people think that there's a one-to-one
relationship between an app service plan
and an app and that costs them money
that cost them a lot of money because a
physical computer if it gets to be
around 50 CPU you'll think I'm this
machine's working too hard I need
another one because I need room to
breathe but in the cloud you don't you
can run these machines hot 60 70 80 CPU
nothing wrong with it if it gets higher
than that then you get another one so
I've got the blog the brochure wear site
the podcast and Azure Friday which is
another podcast that I do all running in
the same single 35 dollar app service
plan and what's cool about that
is I can go back to the plan
and I can look at the memory
app service plans
see I've got six on this Windows basic
and I've got four in this Linux premium
I'm going to click on that let's look at
our memory situation
check out the CPU percentage about 12
percent it's kind of just doing its
thing memory percentage 65 percent that
would be too much on a physical computer
but I wanted this to be as cheap as
possible because I'm going from a free
server from the Canadians to this one
here that I want to pay as little as
possible for it and one of the things
that people don't realize about the
cloud is that Cloud's a little slower
than a physical machine
it just is like you're always going to
feel like it's not quite as fast as your
actual machine because there's a lot
going on on the cloud and you're sitting
next to other people on the same virtual
machine but the thing that the cloud
gives you a lot of is RAM
so when you hear about Cloud native what
does that mean to have a cloud native
application that's an application that
knew about the cloud at the time that
you architected it
cloud has a lot of memory memory is
cheap
so I have a Blog and the blog has no
database
Das blog it's well known for its most
famous feature which is no database
because databases cost money
and it's just a Blog
so let me show you
what the internals of the blog are
let me see if I oh you know what I
actually don't have I just realized
that this computer I rebuilt from
scratch
so let's try
this doesn't have what I need on it
so you know what we're gonna do friends
live
on this machine that barely works right
now
is let's try remote desktopping into my
house
you said right
if I remember the password it's right
I use an app called tail scale it's a
mesh VPN network it's free it's amazing
so if this works it's amazing if it's
not works then it's not tailscale
and I forgot the internet here sucks
oh there you go okay there's my desktop
I know where everything is so shut up
Savages
why are you so mean
um
where I know where everything is
I'm pretty sure everything is blog
backup here we go
see if you can do better if you're
you're empty
empty desktop
okay there's dog's blog
that is
4964 XML files in a folder
you laugh now
but I've been blogging for 20 years it
works just fine
you know I mentioned a little bit uh and
the uh in the opening keynote about how
the world is just name value pairs in
the cloud it's just a big distributed
hash table right XML Json
any files ini file it doesn't matter it
just doesn't freaking matter you can
laugh at that the file system it's like
it's a goddamn good database
I can do random access
but you know what I can do with a lot of
RAM
I can load every blog post for 20 years
into memory and hold it there
how much memory do you think that is
20 years of blog post every Tuesday and
Thursday two decades 365 times 20 times
2 plus content
guess
12 gigs gentlemen said try again
100 megabytes that's a little well kind
of just swung entirely in a different
direction
384 Megs
my life's work fits in less than a half
a gig
no pictures that's a great I love that
you brought that up he says no pictures
though
good point where do the pictures go
we're Cloud native now
CDN you say CDN CDN exactly
so I want this to not just move to the
cloud I want it to be better
so I got a lot of memory so I increased
my cash I no longer seek to the hard
drive so when I press F5 I don't hear
the hard drive because it's already in
memory it's only a couple hundred Megs
so I have an in-memory database these
files are just loaded up on Startup
don't worry about it it doesn't matter
you're not going to need it well you
could have used mongodb Scott well I
could have done a static site generator
that would have been even cleaner right
I'm using the in-memory stuff as a
static site generator it's just I
statically generated the site in memory
and not on disk the concept is the same
and my my um my seek time is Sub sub
milliseconds three four five
milliseconds it's nothing because Ram is
cheap so
uh Graphics I want the site to be better
how can I do that well we can take good
use and smarter use of
DNS
let's go to hanselminutes.com
and we'll go on episodes and we'll right
click on these people and we'll say open
image in new tab
what's that
that is a c name that's a subdomain
you make a CDN it sits on top of azure
storage you drop an image into the thing
you apply the CDN to it now you get two
benefits one all the images are in a
Content distribution Network which means
that they're closer to the user which
means my Indian blog readers and my
Australian blog readers are getting the
image loaded locally in their country
it also means that because it's at a
separate DNS we get parallel DNS lookups
you can have up to three or five on
Chrome I can't remember it's a number
that's bigger than one it's like three
or five and what that means is if you've
got images Dot and JavaScript Dot and
css.the browser will see that there are
three separate websites parallelize the
work instead of them all going to www
so just by moving it to another location
uh and a DNS I'm getting a huge speed up
and the CDN is going to be cheaper and
if I go to Azure storage Explorer
which is at storageexplorer.com it's
just kind of like a file explorer for
Azure we open that up I can go and
upload the next week's show by just
dragging and dropping it into the
storage Explorer so here I've got under
quick access I'll make that bigger
I'm spoiled for my internet at home
go to podcast
take a look at this
we've got our shows
and then for each show we've got the
name of the we've got the show number
dot jpeg I'm a big fan of
this style
so for example
I could have had a database with a
column and then the URL for the
particular image but I don't need that I
have a show number
so do you want to know who's on next
week's show
you just go and hack the URL
right
so show next week is show 8 38.
all right so it's Dan from avalonia
who's got a booth outside so you can go
say hi to Dan
maybe that's a security problem maybe
that's a feature I don't know I think
it's pretty I think it's kind of awesome
right
right like who's on after Dan I don't
even know now all right
go and see yeah that's this guy right so
I can just go and upload that stuff now
if I right click on it and say copy URL
that's the actual URL Hanselman at
cdn.blob dot core dot whatever
but by instituting a very simple system
like this there's no database
check out how I do
this is also a bit of a discussion
around architecture and the concept of
yagony you know what yagni is
you are not going to need it
yagni is great
so if we go here to the uh the podcast
and we go to sponsors
because I have a little advertisers on
the show
I'm a big fan of this different style of
development my friends I think that
people make things way more complicated
than they need to and in doing that it
costs them money I don't want to spend
any money
so here's my list of sponsors right here
okay I have an ID and I have the name I
have a URL and I have the image to the
advertisement
that's cool it's a database how often do
I change sponsors like three times a
year
you don't have an admin website and the
whole thing but I have a text file works
just great cost me zero dollars
so here's the part where I'm not good at
Json
this is how I manage my sponsors
I have a show number and I have the two
sponsors for that week
show only comes out on Thursdays I have
to edit that file on Thursdays
you know what I'm saying yeah I could
make it you could but you could make an
app yeah I could
but I have a I have a text file though
and I cash it for a week and it doesn't
cost me anything you know what I'm
saying so I'm looking at this
opportunity to move everything into the
cloud and I'm trying to save money and
I'm making things way way way simpler so
when I actually do my my editing I
record the show and I put everything
into an input folder in Dropbox and I
have an editor that I pay and then she
puts the result into a folder called
output
it's just it's so much simpler and this
would scale this could be a real company
and it still wouldn't matter I would not
need to spend that much now here's the
problem though I go into azure
and I don't feel like I'm a company
though
you have to have a dashboard if you want
to be a company
because you know when you go to a
company and you like go into their Lobby
and they have a TV that's been mounted
not just like on a desk but they paid
someone to mount the TV that's when you
know they've got the money and they have
a picture of the Earth with pins of all
the places that they've done business I
want that for myself
uh but I'm only me
so it turns out application insights
will make a dashboard for you and then
you can buy a TV
so I go into application insights and
they auto-generate this whole dashboard
and I get a TV from like for 300 bucks
at Walmart and I hang it up and then I
put it in my office and when my parents
come to visit I say this is my company
it's pretty impressive isn't it
yeah check it out right average server
response time of five milliseconds
mm-hmm thank you I guess got some
eyebrows from the gentleman in the
second row there five milliseconds very
nice one of those spikes about though
handsome I don't know that's a 100
millisecond Spike there probably a cash
miss or a reset of the cash something
like that what's cool about this is we
hear this talk of 10x Developers
do you hate that
I'm like a 0.5 x developer and they're
telling me I'm 20x behind this is awful
10x developers are meant to make you
feel bad yes there were genius
developers who type faster than you
that's great but what makes a 10x
developer isn't that it's the tools
behind them I'm one person
20 years ago when I was working on three
letter domains I worked on 800.com and
gear.com
websites back when having a website that
had three or four letters was a big deal
because we didn't think people would
type more than four or five letters
we had to hire someone to come and set
up load balancing and they would fly a
consultant in
and we'd buy a box and they'd rack it
into the thing and they'd set it all up
and they'd say don't touch it
configured it to load balance
balance the load
using round robin round robin oh my God
that's a it's a very complicated how
does it work it's a secret sauce you
flew us here to do that
now when you're old you don't have to
have a one-page resume how long is your
resume it's one page right
two four pages what do you have pictures
or a dashboard what what do you got four
pages
you're like an elder Millennial that's
amazing I want to see what your four
page resume looks like that's amazing I
have a three-page resume and the page
two is the 90s
it's like a thematic
I do it like the page two the 90s and
it's just how to load balance
and now that's a check box in azure
so now I just have a two-page resume uh
it's page one and page three and I just
ripped page two out because I was
ashamed uh because for me like you would
hire a consultant they would rack the
servers and then you'd work all weekend
and then your boss would come in and you
say we scaled the website and then you
put it on your resume and then you have
page two
uh and now the the young people at my
company they go oh this website is
taking like a minute to like scale the
uh and it's like a check box
the entire decade that I spent learning
how to load balance across the internet
is a check box now you know what I mean
and then they'll be like it's a new
feature it's a slider bar now you can
slide it slide it and then they get paid
for that it's amazing so I used to feel
bad about that I used to feel like maybe
I need to learn more stuff and then I
realized what a gift that they don't
need to learn that
they're standing on the shoulders of all
that great work I love that the young
people can push the check box
and build a four-page resume out of it
that's amazing congratulations
I I really have no idea what I I
couldn't feel a four-page resume it's
all just check boxes
dashboards what's that
uh we gotta have more pictures that's
true yeah animated gifs will fill up a
resume too when you print them out
um
having something like this makes me feel
like a 10x developer because I'm one
person
and now I can go to my website check
this out this is a feature that I love I
think everybody should do this go to
hanselminutes.com I'm going to scroll
all the way to the bottom check this out
this is the coolest thing I've done all
year
the version of the runtime that I'm
running which tells me the platform
updated itself
a link to the commit that's live in
production right now that's hot and the
build logs from the actual thing now if
you don't want to do that in public you
could just do it like when you're logged
in as admin but think about how cool
that would be at work remember how I
said I didn't trust my computer anymore
I don't know when I deployed last I
don't know what I put into production I
don't know what's going on but now I'm a
10x developer because of the cloud so
I'm going to go and click on the commit
and I'm going to go directly to that
look I can't get to it because of my
breath right click open link is work
check it out
all right looks like my last commit was
November 30th and it was uh some space
I I removed that space
and I ascended into production
that was how my father did it so
I thought it would be a more impressive
it's just
space
is that significant white space it was
to me
and then I can go in here and actually
see the release and see the job and the
actual code and the test that ran
we couldn't even conceive about that
when I was doing this stuff we had a
team to do this kind of stuff so when
they make you feel bad for not being a
10x developer are you using the tools
that will make you that way have you got
your projects on GitHub actions on
devops do you have them in the cloud in
a way that you can be confident about
them do you have a reasonable amount of
tests have you hooked up selenium or
playwright to do real testing in that
space do you know that your stuff runs
on Windows and on Linux the last thing I
want to show you because I'm out of time
is the concept of the reverse proxy
whether it be Azure front door which is
what I use or something like cloudflare
it is significantly powerful because
remember at the beginning I talked about
how the URL was important that Hanselman
slash blog was different than Hanselman
itself
that is because I'm using a reverse
proxy and what that means is
you all didn't notice my website
being upgraded you probably didn't know
any of this was happening that's because
I was running the website in a parallel
location
www.hanselman.com was going to the
machine in Quebec
staging.hansman.com was a mirror of the
site running in the cloud and then I did
a b testing and I put 50 of the traffic
in one place and 50 of the traffic in
the other until I felt confident that
you all wouldn't notice and then I did a
VIP swap
swap the IPS nobody noticed and I slowly
backed off of staging and then I called
the Canadians and I said all right
and now everything's running in the
cloud Isn't that cool
we have the tools we have the tools this
would have taken a team to do this kind
of stuff before last thing on dos blog
Mark Downey who's a wonderful gentleman
from Microsoft who is actually a
Englishman in uh I think he's an
Englishman in Cincinnati and he made dos
blog core
and he is running that now over at
uh Papa string and he's doing active
development on this so this now 18 year
old blog engine is on.net core so I can
go to each of my sites I can tell that
it's running on.net which version it's
running on they're all running on Azure
app service they're running in one Azure
app service and the one last thing I'll
show you was I also while I was at it I
took azurefriday.com
and upgraded it as well
and because I'm a big fan of
of caching
Azure Friday loads a Json file of 700
episodes of azure Friday loads them into
memory and then allows you to just type
what you're interested in
it instantaneously
gives you what you want
because it's all done in memory
people aren't cashing enough
you don't probably need a database and
if you do need a database cache the
stuff anyway real time you don't need it
in real time
every reason I need real-time data no
you don't every five ten minutes it's
real time enough
you cash something
for five ten minutes it's gonna make
your application way faster if I'm only
blogging twice a week then make a cash
for 16 20 hours
five podcast comes out every Friday do
it like that
if your product catalog doesn't change
more than once a day cash the whole
thing memory is cheap Facebook holds the
entire social graph in memory
billions of people in memory it's way
easier just hold it all in redis big
distributed hash table in the cloud
isn't that great so that's kind of how I
moved all of this stuff to the cloud
systematically and slowly one piece at a
time putting things in as many places
that are static as possible avoiding
having to run a Windows Server getting
it to work on both Linux and Windows
using WSL locally to test on adding in
Docker because I want flexibility about
where I'm going to put this stuff and
then hiding it all behind a reverse
proxy so no one knew I was doing it
end of speech
cool any questions any fundamental
disagreements and thank you for being
such a good sport that was really cool
any thoughts comments questions
all right well you don't have to go home
but you can't stay here
yeah that's a great question so the
question is what if it was like a web
forms application it was
so that's a great question dos blog was
a web forms application but it was well
factored where there was a runtime
engine which was list of blogging you
know list of blog posts list of comments
stuff like that so I had a a layer
because it was done in the classic
three-tier style you know view model
controller or in this case business
logic database and front end
so 70 of the code was written in.net
standard which moved cleanly to.net core
six we literally have the exact same
code from 17 years ago recompiled and
the only thing we changed was the paths
but when we got to web forms we had
these weird templates we converted them
to razor Pages consuming the same
objects so I had these web form pages
with like a control that would be like a
list of blog posts I changed that to a
for Loop for each Post in posts and then
the template that used to be controls I
switched them to tag helpers in razor
pages so it was tedious but it was
possible now we have actually a direct
mapping between web forms and Blazer
so Blazer server you can go and have
like you have you used a grid we have
that same Grid in Blazer and we have a
whole architecture guide
at the.net website at
dot.net.net and if you go to learn
architecture guides
blazer for web form developers free book
so yeah it was in fact a web forms now
as far as Windows classic it depends
winforms still works winforms is
actively being developed and updated it
works on 4K now and if you have a
winforms application you can update it
to net core six it'll be between 30 and
50 faster and you can do a
self-contained build so you don't need
to install.net on the machine you can
just x copy and you can do
self-contained as a single executable
so you have like baby smash.exe with no
other files when you run it it's
actually a zipped up version of.net that
unfolds into memory
and then it runs in memory and it sits
into a single executable so you could
run it off of a USB stick
so great question awesome
cool
great question so the question is can
you does it prune the dependency tree we
do have a thing called tree trimming
tree trimming imagine you take the
family tree of all of the functions that
your.net application references or use
it you flip it upside down so the tree's
upside down now and you shake it
and you shake all the functions off that
you're not actually using actively
then you would ship system.xml but I
didn't use the XML reader or the XML
right only used the Dom or I didn't I
didn't use any of those functions then
don't ship them
so you tree trim the whole thing and
then if you use reflection which we
would not be able to detect you have to
go and put those into a config file that
says don't pull off those leaves I could
I might use them later but you can tree
trim.net to about 118 Megs
yeah great question so yes tree trimming
works too
isn't this fun
what a wonderful time to be a developer
my friends all right let's go uh
somewhere else